I gotta close out okay less than 10
seconds war zone rated 1906 average
rating 58 players time Andy capped here
we go double those points can I get a
quick win here quick wins anywhere my
night gonna be taken just take my night
I somehow want to try and make it work I
just want to make it work somehow I just
want to make that work somehow somehow
can I get this to work here I want to
remove that light square bishop get rid
of that light square bishop I still have
that open H file maybe I could do
something with it my night right here
pawn push okay I have a piece back the
queen is dead
cooked queen my knight is very strong
right here open the position up now get
my queen wants to be on this diagonal my
bishop wants to be on c5 definitely
discovered tricks do I really want to
pull my truck out for that file let's do
this undermine this pawn queen takes
with check watch out for the forks are
there any Forks on this night I really
want to take that I could take here with
the bishop in I have a main threat they
missed it back to tournament two nine
six two okay 28 minutes remaining
nine six three two - you Bosch mmm okay
all right now I'm a step in the
direction of doing what of I'm gonna do
this I'm okay with giving up that pot I
want to preserve this light-square
bishop and keep this option open
the option to do what maybe I could okay
the option to maybe take here I think
it's still on if castles comes about
okay maybe not
push that night away and get dark square
weaknesses ah I supposed to defend this
pawn okay that's not happening I'm doing
this move on purpose I don't want a
castle I want to exploit this pin
somehow Knight f3 is the plan okay let
me break open this there's Knight takes
bishop let's try this Knight takes here
is good alright I'm just gonna take
right there and I think oh man okay no I
could take this cuz of a pin Bishop here
I take this pawn dark square weaknesses
I'd be on the Brooke as soon as I take
here Knight moves there's gonna be
castles I imagine okay just defend this
and then play up alright I want a clean
trade somehow get a Queen trade oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no no no no no they
didn't do it
Oh what it doesn't have to be so hard Oh
Bishop takes Knight would have been a
killer Oh pawn push I could take that so
difficult oh I just have to go for time
yeah you know the drill time burner that
is a time burn if I have ever seen one
oh man Bishop takes Knight check and
then I have a dead Queen it's the dead
Queens variation 1712 six six twenty six
minutes remaining
oh I didn't mean to do that alright
let's stay focused here c'mon regroup
stay focused now you know that
that was not that funny man that was not
that funny quit what you're laughing you
think everything is just a joke here
don't you
this is serious business this is serious
business right here
these war zones what was my opponent
doing whoa
giving up the light square bishop the
light square bishop oh hang on Oh
looking for a killer main watch oh no no
I could take that mate threat still
possibilities for main threat or not I
wanted to open up this file oh boy
defend defend please looks a little
weird definitely looks a little weird
get out of there Knight you are just you
have trouble written all over you don't
you okay I have to defend like this stop
that what they're to play here and then
block with my knight that rook 18
seconds we have 18 seconds of course you
only have 18 seconds you started with
very little time very little time here
very little time where are the winning
moves Oh
where are where are those winning moves
13 seconds remaining
what is that move even do what does that
move even do King position grab here
stay on coordinated squares whatever you
do is stay coordinated stay coordinated
okay let's trade King position King
position King position King position
right here first okay let's get my King
out pawn push on push anything keep
going avoid stalemate King position back
to term in twelve fifteen twelve twelve
all oh man I'm feeling better already
just for a brief second I think last
time already at this point I was feeling
like
okay I wanna I wanna crawl into a corner
and cry oh man okay here we go
efore efore and this Grand Prix land
this pond is are really gonna be taken
okay maybe I could exploit that queen
position not really was that really
exploiting that Queen position they're
trying to fishing pull me or something
they might get just that oh man oh no
what are you doing to me Knight right
here Knight here next to defense stuff
hit the bishop defending here get out of
there I cannot deal with you I'm not
really gonna take that night what am i
doing I'm gonna weasel around here Queen
trade okay is that not gonna be trapped
he might he might be trapped time is
even fortunately
okay that's a very cramping move how do
i untangle myself
it's the untangling phase right now if
you did not know it's time to untangle
it's the untangling phase Knight is hit
keep that Knight boxed out okay now
everything is nice and cozy that Bishop
is kind of dead come over here
22 what's the clock account on that
night nights gonna play here no he's not
he's dead
could've taken that pond probably a
couple times they're gonna resign they
might resign 15 yes they resigned back
to term in 2023 20s okay
oh no defend f2 and f7 defend f2 and f7
defend f2 and f7 alert that's what
that's what this guy's name is defend f2
and f7 boom
that's my defense you will know hit me
with this scholars mate no never again
I've had nightmares over that
oh man
defend f2 and f7 if you play against
Anton squared
I'm telling you right now he will beat
you up oh man oh man
pine pitch is probably good or is it now
it's okay my [ __ ] is protected no I
don't want to do that let's do this
maybe I should have whoa oh why did I
move my queen I should have just let's
try it again
Oh check make it two that's what I
needed
don't milk your clock okay good back to
chairman that was a helpmate 30:29 2018
18 hmm let's close out of that okay Edie
play against Edie twenty minutes and a
handful of seconds remaining in this one
okay okay gain space run around in this
direction support your Center my knight
wants to be right here exchanges go like
that my king is gonna run to f1 I don't
want to block with my bishop I don't
think no I don't want to do that I want
to keep pieces on the board and now the
bishop has trouble I think
let's get over here I've pressure on
this so there's no f6 idea not yet at
least
they might be working towards that okay
now maybe I could get at this square how
come my queen get here g4 b 4 and then
Bishop e3 or just maybe do this right
away probably that right away move my
knight and then get my queen of g4
looking for me that's the plan that is
the plan Knight takes here is not good
when g4 wins the house mate threat
problems against here in here Knight
here might be needed I could take though
that's me that wasn't defending back to
tournament 42 29 28 28
okay leg leg Olas Legolas okay whoa
everybody's going after f7 and f2 now
you fall for once scholars me and
everybody gets on your case Wow Wow
see what happens you've everybody
studies up on you is that what's going
on here
you fall for once collars me and then
that's it Queen c7 I should have played
so you can't develop here I shut this
Bishop out maybe okay he's out he's out
of the ball game the B files opened up
now the B file b3 Bishop here no now
that Bishop is officially dead I think I
should probably just take here what's
keeping me from taking there I should
probably do that they don't have a
light-square bishop around jump in here
remove this Knight and it's game over
I could remove that knight Knight g4
Knight here to remove this guy and then
that's gonna be it Knight here no
there's Bishop check I'd probably be
good right move this night and it's
gonna come with it oh oh I almost just
felt for me it might still be made
somehow no my knight my Kings right away
I totally missed that one
oh is that dangerous did you hear a
giant gasp for what I'll have to relist
to that one Queen h7 I didn't even give
that a second to think about what might
have been that could have been a mean
too if I had a piece right here that
would have been in a corner crying
already
56 41 they're down on time 56:41 the
king of the cube is here and has
something to say okay
stay focused stay focused
play back in g3 pawn push this is a pen
this is a pen oh ok Queen here if pawn
push ok I want to what do I want to do
um get this pawn going yes this is
definitely what I want to do I should
have taken that this is better come back
Bishop here would have been best
let's take here move my queen and then
pawn push pawn push next no that's not
really working ok I have control over
this square pawn push next no this is a
mate threat mage the main threat that's
made back to tournament 2 7 o 72-54
72-54 46 ah ok NYC is up there with 28
oh I'm gonna have this ok French French
put pressure on v6 Bishop d7 I went upon
in this line ok Oh Knight right here no
it's not really gonna work you have that
dark square Bishop maybe expand over
here I don't know if I really want to
take that dark square Bishop right away
f6 is the other move I could be looking
forward to maybe I should have stopped
that I'm winning this pawn I had 3 on it
Queen trade another pawn watch out for
each 7 watch out for 87 right here
tricky forks that's winning everything
hitting the Queen and the bishop and the
rook soon right back to tournament 90 90
55 54 54 uh-oh uh-oh
Popeye I need to get pop hi back can I
get a game in against Popeye
can I can I win a game ok can we get
this right here oh that would have been
bad that would have been bad
okay expansion in the center Queen e2 c3
is gonna be hit I have this okay three
versus two stop
okay I'm not too concerned about that am
i this majority going the Knights gonna
play here I have g3 though I have this
this pine is very deep right now it's
connected there's gonna be a check but I
could defend with my queen and then
recapture with my knight to defend the
PI could I have taken that the Knights
gonna play here okay
doubling rooks isn't that gonna be good
take with my queen take with my con cuz
it's passed let's do this
defend this pawn clock situation my
knight needs to do something else and
their Knight is doing something else as
well Queen here let's defend this pawn
push is still going to be strong Knight
right here Knight right here maybe now a
pound push I sneaked this away is that
night gonna be trapped okay I need to
sneak oh there's a fork down my queen
though where are the tricky Forks tricky
Forks I think I might have a tricky for
k'v ailable check the King can't move
forward ah there's tricky Knights tricky
Knights watch out for those tricky
Knights
time scramble time
ah
I can't breathe I wanna time oh man I
was David playing it again
oh man what an adrenaline rush one
second oh man that felt like a buzzer
beater
oh man who is saying that
oh yeah just it's like watching paint
dry is it really is it really you
haven't played yet let me tell you I've
said it before I'll say it again you
just haven't played enough yet you just
you do not realize do you oh man oh man
you don't realize that there is some
trouble against my king either okay this
is bad news isn't it can I get this
working can I make this work this is
with check this might not be so bad no I
don't want to do that anymore uh get
this night out of there I cannot deal
with that night oh man I get this can I
get this pawn push that's probably not a
good idea I get this pawn push going
take and then here okay I have this beef
I'll open up the beef file is officially
opened up clock situation how are we
doing fine push the Knights gonna play
here want to get rid of that Bishop
somehow
oh boy that night is dangerous isn't he
he is one dangerous piece yes he is he's
got a go my rook needs to defend this
that pawn is falling but oh is that
that's found now that I get that with
two check I need to defend here I need
to get my king I don't know I just
opened up that diagonal why did I do
that why'd I do that why am I in a pen
get out of pins I mean so many pins oh
oh oh wait a second wait a second do I
have something six seconds I have
anything but time remaining that's what
I have that's what I have no sneaky
tricks no maids please where the time
burners there's a time bar
no mates domains please point three a
back to tournament they're down on time
131 19106 I'm losing my breath oh man oh
man oh man 131 19106
176 ah Edie Edie Edie Edie did we
already play in this tournament I'm
losing sight of who i played and who i
did not play i have no idea what I'm
saying right now I really don't it's
always a big surprise when I sort of
watch watch it over again a little bit
before posting to youtube but yeah okay
can I get my Jeep on working please can
we get the Jeep on working and watch out
because your queen is it your queen is
hit did you really mean to do that
man this is gonna be dangerous very
dangerous very very dangerous stuff
going on right here okay I got to keep a
night out of here i weakened this but
what can you do Queen here and now
everything is gonna be fine if I push
right i coordinate my pieces and this
pawn isn't a pin unless that move is
played
okay let's defend stuff a bunch of
trades I'm okay with that I want my king
to be safe who doesn't that was the
statement of the century right there
right who doesn't want their King to be
safe my I think my pieces are lagging
get out of there I just I can't deal
with you anymore clean tricky forks
night right here threat I'm also just
getting ready for a Queen trade that's
always nice clean here I could have done
that for I just want the Queen's off
though should I've done the floor it I
should have okay now I got it
yeah I got it no matter what grab that
rook and then come back defend the
seventh get my king out of harm's way
over here watch out for that tricky
night here he comes here he comes
there's a fork what can you do
he is bound to land a fork and he did
just that but there was no time 150 139
130 126 oh man eight minutes remaining
this is craziness Oh was that a slip f3
yeah oh that would have been bad now
that would have been illegal as well
pawn push not here made me get a fork
get that Bishop out of there and I think
I want to do this move before that move
comes in okay I'll go in a clean trade I
will definitely go with the clean trade
hit this pawn pawn push I want to rip
this pot out he is the heart of this
structure this guy is weak let's come
back I don't know why
good reasons for all these moves not at
all not even close not even close to
having good reasons for these moves the
night I don't want to play here that's
why I did a six I mean a prevent as
usual
what is that Bishop up to what is his
what is his plan
really okay past connected pawn a past
connected pawn I'm okay if takes I am
really lagging here these pieces aren't
going to these squares fast enough now
as fast as I would like
tricky discoveries hard to avoid uh-oh
that's close to mate isn't it I'm just
gonna take that pawn if it pushes
exploit this pin attack pink pieces
discovered double check soon attack the
King Bishop here rook here anything
really
the King is very active where's main two
threat with my LightSquared bishop one
two lobbyists lick me right there let's
back up this king look at him he is a
fighter get out of here
that's it kept chasing after me 170 159
150 no at school this guy is new at
school here six minutes remaining
is this gonna be a problem F - Anton
knows all about that square all about it
alright let's pin this Knight he's gonna
be a problem if he get here I'm just
gonna take care maybe voluntarily okay
now we have this you have some good
pressure on the F file let me get rid of
that dark square bishop first and then
pawn push or rook here okay I thought if
tags and the rook came over I don't know
if I would do pawn push or rugby one get
this majority going no I should have
just taken it would have been simpler
okay I think this is still I write this
pin has to be annoying pawn takes they
take with the night and now I'm in check
but I come back and I'm back on this the
Queen has to go back home she's not
going back home this Queen and now I got
the bishop I got that fish up its check
and then this maybe there was something
better
I had a bishop check anything I could do
that one this is probably in anything
with check rook up this isn't anything
with check bishop here mate in one or
two Podesta push rook here
Bishop check and then me and one and
then two the King has to go to g8 back
to tournament 190 179 170 oh man gnar
never --is-- four minutes and 44 seconds
remaining oh my goodness going for f7
every time not quite Bishop c4 would
have been threatening that okay in here
kick this Queen over around and get my
LightSquared Bishop on that best dog and
I'll width tempo maybe even with more
tempos the queen is getting kicked
around quite a bit
still getting kicked around and still
getting kicked around a reason not to
bring that Queen out so early I almost
just drop my Queen by the way forgot my
queen was hit okay I want to open this
up I think I have still potential for an
attack against the King pawn push is
that going to be played do this pawn
push Bishop c5 now let's do it more be
more cautious here for a second I'll do
this and take away from the center to
open up this dog and I'll have two
bishops that are bearing right down
against that King pawn push and then h4
and get this in and I could play here I
just step up and then king f7 to kick
him out of there okay this is gonna be
tough
do this night here I feel leave it gets
trapped with rook g8 I should have done
this to keep it on the same file as the
king yeah that would have been better
definitely would have been better pawn
takes I just come over making one threat
the pawn is pinned that's me
yes it is back to terminal 2 10 199 this
guy does not go away
210 199 190 if he wins he could get 20
points I'm only up 11 3 minutes
remaining
I could get one more in for sure but I
don't know about a second one 253
remaining
oh man 253 I could get this one in at
least this one I should have just jumped
in the center with tempo I'm on em 7
kick this night away kick this night
away and then the knight might jump into
e3 like right now before I take this
pawn it might jump in here
okay it's not jumping in there this pawn
is pinned I think I can't let's come
over here
I can't maintain this pawn if it's
challenged actually now I can if the
knight was still here probably not but
now I could recapture with pieces clean
here I think I might be able to do Queen
okay this is a main threat I can't take
my bishop his Mayton one pawn push I
think I just sack okay and now what do i
do what do I do
I do what I do centralize take this pun
also Queen trade I guess I can never
turn down a clean trade really my
bishops pinned yes he is
pigs king upon endgame I think my king
my king is there in just in time now I
got a count and stuff ah nobody likes to
have to count come on I have to count
now I want to have to count there oh you
know what I need to do this move okay
now I don't know I wanted a week in this
square my king should have just been
going back and forth here for the whole
game or in this final position pon da
pawn up King keeps going back and forth
eventually the King has to go back this
next okay let's come over here
is he gonna run out of moves yet he's
almost out of moves he's almost out of
moves I want to take this pawn and then
come back pawn push on push next keep
going okay there was the sneak attack
that was the sneaky move right there 40
seconds remaining back to chime in to 39
I need a quick resigner that guy got two
games in apparently this is the AH this
is the pack leader he's gonna just
notify me if anything ah this is the one
guy I didn't want to see oh this is the
guy that's in first ah man I gotta try
something sneaky I have to try something
sneaky he's not gonna let this one go no
way no way he says if anything I will
just milk the clock just take my bishop
would you I should have just are they
gonna make us play this for now now
they're calling it ah man what ooh
third place forget about second oh ah
that guy had tea naive
the head right there t9 ah man good
games everybody good games
oh what a tournament - 39 - 30 - 31 96
Ben Koji was not long enough 176 a syrup
17 out of 17 for Hugh and T night that's
fantastic
very nice